hi there Steve Kaufman first of all I
want to announce that I'm doing a
webinar on how to improve your English
and I'm doing it that's the 6 p.m.
pacific time which is morning time in
Japan because we have a lot of users of
link and people who watch my video who
live in Japan the last webinar was in
the morning which is not so convenient
for people in Asia I'm going to speak in
English but I'm going to speak very
slowly and clearly hopefully and so you
can ask questions you know nihongo de in
Japanese young drama and you know
Chinese Podolski of Jose in espanol of
George any language you want you can ask
questions but I'm going to speak in
English if I'm asked to answer in
another language i will i'm going to
talk about what i consider to be the 7
key steps to improving your English
because after all a lot of people are
learning English I'm learning polish I'm
on my 90 day challenge i'm in palm
springs tomorrow my sons Mark and Eric
who lives in London England are arriving
here we're going to celebrate my 70th
birthday and they're going to spend six
days here with us every time I come to
Palm Springs something bad happens last
time I ruin my back I got something in
my eye I got food poisoning this time
before leaving vancouver i fell playing
hockey kind of jammed my elbow into the
ice and pushed up my shoulder now my
shoulder is sore and then we get here
and the air conditioning doesn't work so
we have to get someone in to fix it it
gets kind of warm in the evening so we
go to a hotel at night which the
development is paying for so lots of
stuff happening but I and of course with
my kids here I won't have as much time
to work on my polish but all that
doesn't matter
we all have fun learning languages we
get in the time that is available to us
but please come to my webinar I'll leave
a link here in the explanation if you
are interested in joining me to talk
about how you could improve your English
please do so and i look forward to
seeing you it'll be there for this
friday 6 p.m. pacific time someone's
haunting me so that's it we'll see you
friday which is saturday morning in asia
bye for now